it's great to be joined today by Rick
Wilson who is a seasoned Republican
strategist also author of the
best-selling book everything Trump
touches dies which is releasing in
paperback with new material Rick really
a pleasure having you on
thank you David I appreciate it so from
my audience which is overwhelmingly
left-wing sure they may not know your
background in being both a Republican
strategist but someone who is not a
supporter of Donald Trump so merely to
sort of get everybody up to speed on on
you what is it about your values and
political views that did not allow you
to support Donald Trump well I'm not a
fan of authoritarianism statism crony
capitalism government directed to you
know as a profit Center for an
individual family or or frankly the the
appearance in American political life of
what is essentially a royal family set
aside from the fact that you know Donald
Trump is also a moral vacuum and a
terrible terrible human being a bad
businessman a bad leader a bad
negotiator in a bad just about
everything and and deeply compromised by
his own personal weaknesses there this
whole combination of factors led me to
the point where I could not as a as a
principle limited government
conservative stand up and support this
guy why do you believe it is that he
maintains such a high level of support
among Republicans
well we've right now got a country
that's very much divided to media and
political silos and Republicans have
basically abandon all the things that
they used to be about in terms of
conservative principles which is to say
constitutional fealty limited government
individual liberty and basically they
they in turn what I call entertainment
republicanism where they like the show
they like the spectacle they like Trump
owning the libs they like the hissy fits
and them and the Emmy anger and the
stomping feet and they like the the
screamy twitter feed and the rage
tweeting and they've replaced
conservatism with that are there things
that Donald Trump has either proposed or
accomplished that you are pleased with
not particularly because III look at the
policy direction
the administration they always point to
regulatory reform regathering rollback
well look does the government regulate
too much and in too many areas
absolutely but what they did with this
administration was they got a laundry
list from donors who literally gave them
a shopping list with money and said do
these things for us
that's not deregulation in the way that
I think we ought we ought to look at
reducing the regulatory overlay in this
country that's just pure crony
capitalism so I'm not really a fan of
any of the policy directions he really
hasn't accomplished a whole lot else in
terms of the administration he kind of
picked up the ball and signed it on
criminal justice reform but that has
been something that the that folks like
me and the right on crime movement have
been working on for 15 years to try to
reduce mandatory minimum sentences and
to reduce sentences that
disproportionately affect African
American and other voters are there any
either executive orders policy reforms
anything that Donald Trump has done that
you see as as sort of left-wing
accomplishments aside from whether you
as your conservative like them just
whether you see something that sounds to
you more like a left winger than a right
winger sure this is a president who very
much believes in expanding the power of
the executive expanding the power of the
government and I think that that it's
ironic that a lot of people who were
quote unquote tea party conservatives
are now cheerleading when Donald Trump
you know expands the size of the
government by adding you know wants to
add a hundred thousand officers to ice
and Border Patrol wants to use the power
of the Oval Office to manipulate
businesses and where they can build
factories or where they can't wants to
use the power of the presidency to start
a trade war which i think is a
fundamentally unconservative economic
decision so a lot of things that that
that it's not even progressive it's it's
more one of the lines of statism and
that's where I think Donald Trump is
very comfortable in that status space do
you see the use of the national
emergency as an example of the sort of
expansion of executive power to get
around the will of the House and Senate
absolutely the the executive the the
emergency declaration was something that
that if Obama had done it in the same
scope which is to say doing something
contravention of the Constitution
article 1 section 9 of the Constitution
which is to say the Congress is the
control source of the money they
appropriate the money that must be spent
for the things they appropriate that
money on if Barack Obama had done that
Republicans would be outside the White
House with pitchforks and torches and so
this emergency order is definitely a way
for Trump to attempt to expand and very
dramatically expand the scope of
executive power and I object to that not
only as a constitutionalist but as a
conservative I want to get your sense on
whether there is something unique about
the fact that most Republicans are
continuing to support Trump or not and
I'll frame it up in this particular way
but moral psychologists like Jonathan
hight for example in the rational mind
have talked about sometimes it seems as
though individual voters are voting
against their own best interests or
their stated values so you gave the tea
party conservatives voting for
expansions of government as an example
sure what Haight argues is that we're
looking at the wrong sort of zoom level
that we shouldn't be analyzing their
actions on the basis of their personal
priorities or stated goals but rather
how they perceive it as being part of
the group priorities of the group they
identify with is it as simple as that is
it as simple as Republicans nominated
this guy I'm a Republican so I support
him well it's also a matter that there
is an entire media infrastructure now on
the far right and the Trump right that
has been very malleable in its
ideological groundings so Fox the
largest television nation station our
network in the nation reaches 90 million
households it is overwhelmingly watched
by Republicans they are the
agenda-setting feature of the media
landscape on the Trump right and because
they've been so malleable because
they've they've reduced this now to
purer tribalism and not to ideological
points or ideological policy questions
you've got them very much reflexively in
defense of Trump because to to not
defend Trump in their minds now
according to the to the Fox Nation is to
lose to the libs is to give in the
progressive socialist communist and tifo
whatever fantasy version of the left of
it's in there
so that it's both the tribalism and the
media reinforcement mechanism that
together combined to be a very powerful
influence on the on the the way the the
rights ideological homogeneity has
developed around Trump what do you think
is the long-term impact of this
presidency in other words is it going to
open up the door to sort of a permanent
course inning of political discourse and
the sort of irrelevance of political
positions is this going to kind of
rebound back for the Republican Party
look I think it's gonna it's look we
already saw that 40 Republicans lost
their seats in the 2018 election because
they ran content-free campaigns based on
Donald Trump it was a referendum on do
you love the Dear Leader or do you not
love the Dear Leader most people do not
love the Dear Leader 65 to 70 percent of
people in this country do not love the
Dear Leader so the Republican Party
rebranding itself as a Trump party
solely as a party dedicated to and
driven by Donald Trump that that in that
regard they have abandoned all the
ideological infrastructure that would
allow them to walk back and say let's
take a deep breath
let's sit around a table let's negotiate
an issue let's talk something through
and look both parties have forces within
them that are driving that you know
edges out the dialog style because it's
now you know and you know to to put the
shoe on the other foot on the Left it's
like no you can't even question aoc in
the green new do you can't even ask a
question about it because suddenly
you're you're violating all of your
loyalty to the progressive cause you
can't even say is if it's a thoroughly
thought out plan if you're on the web
you can't do that because there's a
similar set of behaviors in both tribes
to talk out to the edges and not into
the center yeah I've experienced that I
mean just pointing out that there have
been missed just flat-out missteps on
economic policy from AOC I was no longer
sort of part of the in-crowd that was
saying this is the future and everything
about this is great I'm curious so in
2016 there were he's um on the left I
was not one of them who were of the
mindset that Hillary was the wrong
direction for the Democratic Party so
who cares if it's Trump because we want
to tear it all down to at some point in
the future
build it back up that wasn't my politics
I'm curious where you are in terms of do
you want to see a primary challenge to
Trump do you want to see a Democrat win
in 2020 what what is your path forward I
would love to see a primary challenge to
Trump I'd love to see a principled small
government legitimate conservative who
could mount a serious and meaningful
effort against Donald Trump is that
person out there right now
not yet he's not bill well that sounds
like you're saying hmm I like okay I do
I like Bill he's affable he's eccentric
I kind of loved those things about him
yeah but I don't know that bill well
mounts a credible national campaign
against Donald Trump you know and is
able to rally a meaningful fraction of
conservatives to say okay let's reboot
from one eccentric to another eccentric
and like I said I would love to see that
I don't know where that hypothetical you
know person is or who that is and I know
these guys pretty well I'm kind of an
expert on these people and and you know
the other option of course is some sort
of principled centrist independent
candidate and you know you've got a
you've got a Howard Schultz up there
right now but it looks like he's you
know having a rough start but we'll see
where that goes you may end up with
other independents in the race you may
end up another center right or Center
left people in the race and the
Democratic primary field may it may end
up having a very very very crowded
progressive lane on the far left where
you've got the Bernie's and the Warren's
and the camel Harrises and a less
crowded Lane in the center left of the
clover char's and maybe the Biden's of
the world and it's gonna be interesting
to see how that plays out so look I
think Donald Trump is a disaster for
this country politically and morally and
in every other dimension sorry the crows
and my ponder that's why maybe it's a
sign yeah but I think Trump is a
disaster in almost every axis but look I
also know one thing about the Democratic
Party and guys like me beat Democrats
across this country for years and years
and years you know since 2008 we took
1,100 seats of the Democrats oh you went
about 300
in 18 but we took about 11 receipts
because the Democrats as a party are not
holistically good at politics they are
good at elements of politics they're
good at the casting element they get a
Barack Obama Bill Clinton they find a
real talent once in a while they're not
as good as at the operational elements
of politics so I was good at the at the
nuts and bolts of politics and and
they're really not as good at speaking
American because they they they convince
themselves that the policies they want
to talk about are the ones that voters
really care about and they rarely are
yeah you're gonna lead this election
with climate change gun control and
third term abortion
you know where voters put those things
on their lists of most important issues
quite low in the single digits yeah they
care about the economy they care about
jobs they care about their their
personal financial situation they care
about their kids they care about
education they care about a country and
a government that feels disconnected and
arrogant and distant and they and and
for folks on the left that's not just
the Trump administration they feel that
way all the time
Dior are there's a great collapse in our
country of trust in the institution of
government and trust in the institution
of Congress no matter which party's in
control it tends to it tends to not be a
something that voters repose much trust
in and so I think there are more
important ways to go after Trump and to
go after the national election but
Democrats as I like to joke they seek
political death at all times very
similar to the criticisms I've had
unfortunately of the Democratic Party
for years I know you've got a run Rick
but one thing I wanted to ask you about
I in preparation for the interview I
read an article and some of them are
mixing together it's from last year and
it says that you're you either now
regularly carrying a gun and you didn't
previously or your regularly open
carrying when maybe before you were
Caroline I just see it I concealed carry
Florida is a concealed carry state not
an open carry state I concealed carry
because we have had two and a half years
of death threats against me my wife my
kids my dogs we had plenty people up at
the house we've had plenty people
in public you know who get very aggro
and very in my face and there's been a
lot of a lot of harassment and swatting
that's gone on we've had the violent
threats against like I said every member
of my family and so I I can still carry
I'm highly trained I put a lot of rounds
downrange in practice I'm very safety
conscious about it I don't treat it
lightly or frivolously it's not some
sort of like you know far right-wing
macho guy talk that I Weston was going
to be whether that was specifically
because of your anti Trump position
publicly it is absolutely yep absolutely
all right please check out chatter was
fun it is what it is that's for sure and
you outline a lot of it in the book
everything Trump touches dies which is
releasing in paperback with new material
Rick I really appreciate your time today
absolutely David thanks for having me